mon pauvre c'est quelqu'un de dynamique
sa vie et sa passion c'est la tisane
je présente le doyen joseph franze plus
connu sous le nom sur mon cas koukal
entre deux je suis tisaneurs donc de
père en fils mais qu'est ce qui te
demande la réunion est le département où
le diabète est plus élevé en france donc
babioles le cholestérol le cholestérol
l'acide urique donc la goutte
si vous emmène ici qu'est ce que vous
venez chercher des la tisane pour des
douleurs articulaires attiré mois pour
offrir 10 mans et puis la gamme de
savons
la ligne 8 il a b c a bercé toute mon
enfance donc je partais je veux redire
en forêt a commencé à partir en forêt à
l'âge de 8 ans avec mon père donc et du
moment qui avait pas école c'est vrai
que c'est parti très loin non plus à
l'école mais à l'époque on partait du
village à pied on partait à 4 heures du
matin quand on te faisait réveiller à 80
matin des fois deux heures du matin pour
pouvoir monter prendre les sentiers
à l'époque le plateau du mythique venait
d'être d'être abandonnée de garde
oui depuis que je suis petit il est
toujours gelé toujours vais partir dans
la forêt toujours avec 7,6 à mais depuis
je suis tout petit
ça c'est sur la forêt 10600 terrain jugé
on a évolué donc dans dans la tisanerie
à la réunion on va dire parce que ça a
permis donc de faire reconnaître
certaines plantes à la pharmacopée
française de connaître réellement les
molécules donc de nos plantes
donc ça a été ça a été comme je dis
souvent ça a été une aubaine pour nous
donc de de faire valoir les plantes
médicinales de la réunion
moi le message que j'aimerais faire
passer c'est partager cette passion donc
tout en restant respectueux de la nature
surtout bien travailler dans ce milieu
folk et quand je les fais comme je le
fais depuis mon plus jeune âge
on